What we're looking at, is a finite state machine, a state chart that is
carved up into a collection of concurrently executing sub machines. And
the one that we filled in, that pivotal state chart is labeled Display. And
the Display, if you think about it, can be in one of three states.
Either, it can be displaying the current clock time, time of day. The time when
you wish to be awoken. And, the amount of time that you'd like the radio to run,
as you're going to sleep at night. And between these each status is an oval.
And between the states are some transition arcs. And in this case to make it
a little bit simpler, we've abbreviated the two arcs, the ones that go back and
forth with a single arc with double-headed arrow. But in general those are two
transitions and we have to take care that we represent them both